- I truly am a lightweight,
but like, what?
I had three scoops of ice cream!
(rhythmic rock music)
- I'm Chelsea.
I'm a video producer in
New York, and I'm on my way
to Tipsy Scoop, a place
that combines both ice cream
and alcohol, two of my favorite things.
(rhythmic rock music)
- Just tried a bunch of the flavors.
They were all delicious, and
now I'm gonna bring them back
and see what my coworkers think.
- Drinks, alcohol, and
then, like, had ice cream.
But I've never, like, combined it.
- We're hoping that we can find
a really good intersection.
- Yeah.
- I love ice cream, and I love booze,
so I definitely wanna try it.
(rock music continues)
- I wish I could swirl
this like it was alcohol.
- It kinda looks like a Frosty.
- Chocolate whiskey?
I like both of those things.
- Okay.
- I don't really, I don't like whiskey.
But this tastes really good.
- I think chocolate and
whiskey is a good combination.
I never thought about
combining the two before.
- It's really good, it tastes
like that bourbon flavor
you get in a food that's
made with dark liquors.
- It's not super overpowering,
I guess, which is good.
- I also don't really believe you
that there's alcohol in these.
- This would be funny in, like,
an ice cream cake at a birthday party.
- Turn up at the playground.
(cheery electronic music)
- So this definitely gives me more
of a coffee cream kinda look.
- This is good.
- It almost tastes like
a coffee-like martini.
- It tastes like a frozen white Russian.
- Irish cream...
Eh?
That was an Irish-like sound effect.
- It doesn't look like
it's gonna be strong.
- Yeah, it's like vanilla ice cream
that will also get me fucked up.
- There's like a hazelnut
or something in here?
That definitely kinda helps like cope
with the coffee bean flavor.
- I wouldn't order a Kahlua drink,
but, like, I would buy this.
- Our judgment is gonna get slowly skewed.
(island music)
- Really fucking excited
about this mango margarita.
- Are you a tequila person?
- I absolutely am.
- Hell yeah.
- This is better than a
lot of frozen margaritas
I've had in, like, bars.
- That's good.
- Yeah.
- That's really goddamn good.
- I don't like tequila at all.
(laughs) That was strong.
- Yeah, I think that one
tastes the most like alcohol.
- It tastes kind of like
an orange creamsicle.
- Good balance of mango
and tequila, for sure.
- I think we both liked that one.
- Yeah, a little too much. (laughs)
(upbeat dance music)
- This is actually delicious.
- This is really good.
- It's good but I don't
think I want a lot of it.
- Yeah
- This doesn't taste like alcohol at all.
- Like those Italian icee's,
but like an adult Italian icee.
- I'm gonna finish this.
(laughs)
This was really good.
(dramatic music)
(people blowing air)
- 0.0
- I got .03, I can drive home.
- I got .05.
- 0.0.
- I got 0.0000000.
- .07.
(laughs)
That's insane.
- Ah man, I love this!
- This is not a choice,
we were forced to do this.
- I just wish maybe it was
a little more heavy handed,
maybe there's a little
more bang for your buck.
- Maybe with a shot or
more alcohol on top.
- I for sure would like eat,
whenever the hell I wanted to get drunk,
not wanting people to know
that I was getting drunk.
- I would say these were really good,
just tasted like ice cream,
that also gets you wasted.
- "You had anything to drink today?"
Well, I had a lot of ice cream, officer.
(upbeat music)
(woosh sound)